CNBC decided to release a mini
documentary about the dinks more than a
quarter of respondents said they simply
aren't able to financially support a
child at the moment when we advise
clients about having children we
honestly don't even give them the full
real details and the real numbers it's
one of those things if you actually see
the math of it all it might make you
decide to not have children it costs a
family an estimated
$310,500 to age 18 there are families
with significantly less financial means
who are managing to raise multiple
children and can still live perfectly
comfortably and care for their children
and themselves without the risk of
starvation you know as a general rule if
you have decided that something is
financially impossible for you but then
you look around and you see that
billions of people throughout the
history of the world have done this
impossible thing with less financial
means than you have at your disposal
that's a good indication that the
problem isn't really your finances